serge gainsbourg il ya une tradition
dans cette émission se soit l'auteur qui
nous dise quel est le sujet de son livre
et nous présente le ou les personnages
principaux en l'occurrence la lionne un
seul et s'appelle evgeny sokolov alors
qu'ils avaient bu ni ce que l'ofs
a priori c'est moi avec une distorsion
francis beck parler du printemps c'est à
dire j'espère que c'est à dire un truc
coeur comme je suis un truc
tu finis
sa vie que mu l'a commencée dans les
affres de
et oui chères
je vous laisse étape enflé de la
peinture moderne que j'ai pu j'ai abordé
ne l'était pas
jeunes moins 30 ans avec andré vote et
fernand léger que j'ai abandonné parce
que après avoir abordé toutes les
techniques peu s'empare impressionnisme
le fauvisme cubisme expressionnisme et
j'ai perdu ma voix
ou alors j'étais peut-être peut-être par
l'acheter parce que je trouvais que que
la bohème et est un anachronisme
donc il faut prendre ce petit livre
comme un pamphlet contre la peinture est
tous des arrivisme quels qu'ils soient
dans tous les arts oui alors ce faut
quand même dire qui est ce personnage
bon il a une partie va et et
physiologique mais j'en vois des vents
c'est ça sans arrêt on peut pas se
maîtriser
non au contraire y cultive cette
formation est au départ c'est
particularités physiologiques
l'empêchent de créer puisque évidemment
s'il est dans une situation instable
si on peut dire oui alors donc et
l'empêchent de créer mais il va bientôt
découvrir comment au contraire
lee mais ça c'est la vingtième
physiologiste voilà et l'a finalement
c'est grâce justement à cet avatar
physiologiques comme vous dites qu'il va
devenir un grand peintre
mais comment alors ils créent ce vous
avez réalité réalise les perles hyper
abstraction c'est ça et il crée des gaz
ou g que je sais que les gazous g ya de
graves délits ac ne ils ont 50
paraboliques sur le vent le vent qu'il
aimait par le fond devant lui donne une
pulsation d'une pulsation à son bras qui
fait dévier son sa main il donne donc
donne à sa main fonctionnel séisme grâce
et alors les critiques disent il est
génial
alors vous dites plus critique par l'air
d'hyper abstraction d'insistance
stylistique de mysticisme formelle de
certitude mathématique de tension
philosophique d'eurythmie rare de
lyrisme hypothético déductive et
certains août quand même de
mystification de bluffer de kaka mais
pour vous vous rangez parmi les seconds
ils pensent que c'est parce que c'est du
bluff 12 à fait comme vous pensez qu'ils
n'ont qu'une partie de la peinture
moderne c'est du bluff c'est du caca
oui je ne citerai personne non sur bon
évidemment tout ça va finir mal oui il
finit par exploser
wakefield hier simon carr payer sa
fourberie meurent par les gaz ce qui me
paraît tout à fait normal d'envoyer il
essaie d'abord une une tentative de
suicide à une période maniaco dépression
et une tentative de suicide par les
guerres intestines
vous avez fait en modèle réduit une
sorte de autant en emporte le vent en
algérie
1 on a déjà dû vous le dira plus de nos
enfants n'ont pas ça va encore on va
parler de pétomane en lasse je le
rejette
ah non non pas du tout ce que le
pétomane n'existe ni dans le littré et
dans le grand larousse né dans le robert
c'est un nom donné aux un surnom de nid
ne met plus pujol qui officiait 19 oui
lui délivre d'ailleurs sur lui raconte
l'arrière de france voyant ce qui est
évidemment le sujet scabreux jamais
d'être souhait d' atroce mais vous êtes
vous avez dû vous dire plus le sujet
scabreux plus le style doit en être
rigoureux exec traîne alors c'est là où
vous êtes amusé quand finalement c'est
un sujet que vous amusez ce sont les
mots j'ai mené en premier
a priori je n'ai pas d'idée son second à
la r d autres qui ont des idées que font
véhiculer les mots moi j'ai des maux
alors il ya des mots très rare très
savant il semble que vous ayez me
semble-t-il
à moins que je sois coupe complètement
dupe mais vous avez dû et étudié de très
près la chimie et puis la médecine non
bien vous savez que la notoriété vous
prête des pouvoirs que d'aucuns n'ont
pas j'ai pu avoir accès aux archives
bibliothèques faculté médecine et là je
suis tombé sur des documents étonnants
dont 1/2 véridique de zone on éclate et
sont parents durant l'intervention d'une
électro régulation mais ça va donner
dans une fin sublime mon héros et je
suis je suis reparti en flash back sur
le
oui c'est bien ce que je disais donc
vous avez quand même
ah ouais je disputerai près le langage
chimiques comme lg bibliothèque est
bourré de d'ailleurs j'ai des références
mauvais de travaux regard des vaches 46
ha oui oui ah oui là toute une baisse et
juin
c'est me suis demandé si c'était
dénombrait bélier vrai et tout ça dont
vous avez lu la composition actuelle des
gaz intestinaux études de leurs limites
d'explosivité dans leur mélange avec
l'air de rachel busson et debré voilà
deux fameux debré qui va sauver la vie
en 1941 quand je le père de notre noble
le mais théoriquement pathologie gastro
intestinaux vous avez vu tout ça au
sérieux
les gens disent en six ans pour un chien
ce petit vivre lors c'est une nouvelle
c'est une 6 à 16 ans quelques grammes
vous savez qu'une lettre piégée qui vous
saute à la gueule si oui oui mais là ça
mais une super six en support a dit que
je mets ma fille oui vous avez créé des
chansons chantées qu'autre chose donc à
bon six ans alors fournir au langage
parce que j'ai pris au mot par exemple
j'ai plus ou moins porto l'ocm
j'ignorais n'existerait à gensac un
cocktail pas du tout dans alors ça donne
donc ce goût des mots un peu rare ces
indiens mélange de mots scientifiques et
puis 2 - américain ce qui donne un une
quand les impressions de lecture mais la
parole je tombais sur cette phrase qui
moi je trouve jolie mais ton masque
sokolov que tu es fermentation anaérobie
fasse éclater les tubas de sa renommée
équeuter vent irrépressible transforme
abscisses et ordonnées en deux sublimes
anamorphose où il avait pris
j'ai quasiment du cndd jaune perd son
époque il devient lyrique et devient peu
à côté de la plaque
vous êtes un petit peu quand même un peu
obsédé par les wampas que dans un autre
livre qui est paru cette année mais qui
vous est consacré s'appelle serge
gainsbourg il ya sorte de récit de votre
vie et puis il y a à la fin des des
paroles de chansons et j'ai découvert
une chanson qui s'appelle des vents des
ped et poum 1
en attendant je fais les vents les mais
il ya aussi un petit un petit 4 1 au et
gaz à tous les étages et pas vu ça ah
oui c'est ça oui ça c'est là aussi
milliers de danse une immonde autant
chez cas être je pisse et goethe est
attendu autour d'étoilés
on a tout le temps avec ma petite kate
sûr de ma voix y est je puisses tu peux
être un montage et quelle moralité
il n'y a pas de moi regarder joyce
oui ah bah oui joyce à ma vie qu'est ce
qu'il a fait je ris ah bah je décide à
écrire est petit à petit nos douze
petites [ __ ] nora je crois que je
pourrais repéré le le sien par de paix
dans une salle pleine de femmes péteuse
c'est un bruit plutôt fillette palper
mouillé lâche que j'imagine chez les
femmes grâce il est soudain essec et
sabin celui d'une petite fille effrontée
des coffrets et nuit pour rire vaste
dortoir j'espère que nora dès que sera
sans fin c'est paix dans la face je
puisse aussi connaître leurs parfums et
vous lisez la revue tel quel
ordinairement ya eu certaines équipes
ont eu plaisir à philippe sollers
il voudrait de sortir un peu de monde y
est ou du show-business
parce que je ne ressens doute maintenant
je suis peut-être ce sigle nrf kate
exaspéré les critiques mais il ya eu sur
ce bouquin un black out total
certains bruits quand l'académie
monsieur oui pourquoi le sig nrf
parce que c'est disons que c'est la rose
medicare mais ça vous a fait plaisir
comme on dit chez gallimard
paraît que entré chez gallimard surtout
qu'en littérature
enfin je dis ça a dû quand même flatter
votre serviette et docile al saoud
voyager j'avais d'autres propositions
bien sûr c'est que même quand même vous
êtes chez l'éditeur de j2 martin du gard
de fauquenhem gérer ajouté de marcel
proust bon et vous êtes quand même vous
êtes quand même un provocateur
professionnel on sait dans vos chansons
mais effectivement ce livre ne peut être
que mal reçu d'abord par a certainement
les peindre des critiques de ceux qui
manquent et il peinture mais aussi par
les critiques littéraires
parce que d'abord êtes un chanteur
célèbre et puis publié un livre un roman
va savoir de gheest au fait mal reçu ça
et en plus de ça vous avez un sujet
évidemment qui est pas je veux dire très
très plaisant à vous en vous savez bien
ça mais c'est plus fort que moi la
provocation pour être une dynamique
j'ai envie de secouer les gens et de
caen vous ce coup égalé les gens il
entend quelques pièces de monnaie a
provoqué signe si je ne provoque pas je
ne peux pas je voulais dire sans
provocation pas de création aussi bien
dans pour écrire des livres que pour
écrire des chansons de même de même dans
mon dernier georges conchon qui a écrit
un très beau texte sur vous il vous aime
beaucoup alors il faudrait pas détourner
ce que je vais dire pas du tout assez
moulant sens il dit vous êtes un
agresseur public un provocateur
insidieux ça me paraît vrai nom ouais
j'ai envie de vous demander si imaginons
que l'on vous dise voilà ça jusqu'à ce
bon on va vous donner une autre vie il
faut choisir où vous allez chez les
jansénistes de port-royal vous chez les
débaucher de caligula ou choisissez quoi
je choisirais de débaucher les gens
chaînistes a pas de facile
la difficulté c'est un bon est ce que
est ce que vous lisez un bon je vois
qu'ils lisent tel quel je lis ici
lichtenberg oui les rebelles à force de
richter
allez-y oui je vous le prête à donner
personnellement vous me donnez aussi
elle quelques téléspectateurs
la leader a ceci de supérieur à la
beauté c'est qu'elle dure